stream nothing in twilight is easy and
while it wasn't always easy it was
pretty often very funny one joke
involved the majority of the main cast
another a hook and sandbag and another
well let's just say the swearing jar on
set was quite full we've got 15
hilarious behind-the-scenes moments
coming right up
number one
it's really not what you think it would
be
who knew these vampires could groove so
hard we really got into it the entire
extended cast we're talking all those in
the vampire coven got together to dance
it out on set in the middle of filming
and we all thought it was the best idea
we'd ever heard that was genius most of
the cast was in on it the camera crew
was in on it but director bill condon he
didn't know what was coming condon was
ready to work but instead of performing
the material everyone was expecting to
film first id called action the music
blasted the sound of sweet dreams by
eurythmics filled the studio and the
vampires got down the actors divvied
themselves up giving strong west side
story dance soft vibes that left
everyone feeling good after the prank
was pulled off bill condon even called
it one of the greatest moments i've ever
had on a set it's a good thing he took
it so well it still amazes me that they
were able to keep it secret
number two
who doesn't like a little bit of romance
i did prank maggie grace carlisle aka
peter fetchinelli decided he'd stir the
onset romance pot pretending to be
another cast member in order to ask
maggie grace out on a date what he
didn't anticipate was just how kind
she'd be to him and it was really
awkward because she was being really
sweet to make it all worse this wasn't a
private affair at all like the cold cast
was in the room though it was really
awkward after going along with it for a
bit fatinelli finally fessed up and let
grace off the hook i told her it wasn't
that cast member it was me grace did
find the whole thing amusing in the end
and wasn't shy to whip out the sass
after finding out just who was actually
asking her out her answer was not up for
debate and then i was like definitely no
number three
on totally dry land how does that make
any sense well if you've ever seen fake
rain on a set you'll know it can be
absolutely brutal sometimes even worse
than a regular rain shower
filming this scene between kristen
stewart and taylor lautner was anything
but enjoyable especially for k-stew this
is ridiculous luckily they laughed
through it a bit but it's clear this was
a tough day
especially considering just how many
takes they wound up needing to do just
to capture the footage needed
number four
sometimes their best efforts didn't
quite cut it cars and doors can ruin a
shocking amount of takes stuck corridors
got the best of taylor lautner and
kristen stewart as much as they tried to
make it part of the scene and film
through they were fighting battles they
were not gonna win not their smoothest
moments
somehow filming some of the more
dramatic moments on set failed to be
tragic and instead were filled with
laughter and shenanigans behind the
scenes an intense and serious emergency
medical moment seemed like the perfect
time for robert pattinson to practice
his cpr with his on-screen romance he
was having a great time stuart on the
other hand not so much
number five this joke fell awkwardly
flat peter fetchinelli was whipping
jokes out left right and center and when
he stumbled upon a card in the store he
figured it would be the perfect
accessory to help him execute his next
prank and i bought it and i signed it
and i gave it to rob so what did this
card say you are not what you do for a
living and the inside read i hope
someday you find the job that's right
for you
ouch fast forward to rob receiving the
card totally confused as to why his
co-star was even giving it to him in the
first place and in the end the payoff
really wasn't worth it since it went
right over pattinson's head and he read
it and he was like oh thank you
he didn't get that it was a joke what
can we say not every joke is a winner
number six enemies on screen bffs behind
the scenes no matter if you're team
jacob or team edward it's evident from
seeing how much these two laugh together
on set that they are anything but
enemies in reality having to film broody
intense scenes was made much harder by
the fact that the actors joked around a
lot resulting in a ton of unusable takes
filled with the actors corpsing on
camera filming the tent scene was meant
to be a very intense chat between the
boys and in the movie it was but on set
neither of the actors could keep a
straight face during the serious moment
they were not going method that's for
sure
number seven
one lead actor also performed as their
own stand-in how exactly
well taylor lautner was up for anything
filming twilight including doing
whatever he could to support his co-star
kristen stewart there's an intimate
moment where jacob joins bella though
we're not sure wearing a gray
non-reflective spandex onesie was
exactly what he had in mind considering
just how awkward and ridiculous it
looked we're glad it was just the one
scene he did this for everything from
the outfit to the silence to the petting
moment was totally cringy we have to do
ultimately his cover taylor up with a
wolf yeah no kidding
number eight
who says there's anything wrong with the
classics peter factionelli pulled his
fair share of pranks on set but
according to him it was actually eddie
gethegi who was the biggest jokester on
set eddie was particularly talented when
it came to changing the sound of his
voice and together with fatinelli they
decided they should take advantage of
the fact by calling co-star jackson
rathbone pretending to be someone from
the production team eddie's prank call
alter ego susie told rathbone we just
want to tell you that we're dying your
hair back to brown because we don't like
the blonde hair rathbone was convinced
and instead of questioning the sudden
change he reached out to his manager
immediately his manager's reaction oh
thank god i hated you with blonde hair
this was a hard dose of reality when
eddie revealed it had indeed been him on
the phone all along leaving ratbone's
manager backpedaling their comments from
before after learning the truth
number nine
people didn't always know which team
they were on though the cast and crew
were getting exhausted loopy from hours
of filming for days on end so a selected
few decided to liven things up a bit
attaching photos of different actors to
people's backs charlie bully printed a
photo of himself in character wrote team
dimitri on it and then made sure to
stick it to nikki reed's back and he got
her good since the actress didn't notice
for hours this set off a whole chain
reaction with photos that said team
bella team edward team cullen team jacob
anything you could imagine stuck to the
back of cast and crew members throughout
the set
number 10
and not in a good way a jokester himself
gary weinberg was the victim of a prank
that got him good and it was all thanks
to a hook and a sandbag a production
assistant attached a hook to his coat
and then to that a sandbag weinberg was
busy chatting with stephanie meyer and
while meyer witnessed the whole thing
she did not let anything slip leaving
weinberg completely caught off guard
when he stood up to walk away only to be
thrust back down in maybe the least
graceful way possible always gotta be
watching your back on these sets
number eleven
and then there was some swearing
noel fischer and gary weinberg started
what became an epic and ongoing prank
while filming and the concept was pretty
simple these castmates would tell each
other to go f yourself yes that was the
game not particularly creative but it
kept them entertained for a shockingly
long time
the gfys team grew to include multiple
cast and crew members including robert
pattinson christian stewart and
stephanie meyer
number 12
the planning was solid the execution
could have used some work bryce dallas
howard wanted to bring some fun to the
set so she enlisted robert pattinson to
help her in pulling off a joke on the
crew the joke was that howard had
pre-planted some hair from rob's stunt
doubles wig in her hand going into the
scene when she was meant to pull rob's
hair but once she did the hair rip rob
awkwardly said
ow
in what was surely one of his worst
acting moments ever howard had hoped
patinson would cause a big scene yelling
and storming off set and he did anything
but twilight is filled with some intense
moments and real drama but the team was
always ready for a laugh and looking at
the behind the scenes footage it's
evident it was typically a pretty fun
time on set even if it was because
everyone was exhausted and feeling loopy
which joke do you think was most
successful